all right i'll get that up my
notifications are exploding right now
good it's your birthday you deserve to
get the subs
so yes it is wade's birthday and we are
playing some seven days to die
you are one oh god you're two you're so
far away why does it keep putting us far
away from each other
are you thanking people i'm assuming
you're thanking people i'm trying yeah
i think i'm cut up for a minute all
right okay so
here's the thing about this game there's
blood moons every night
what there's blood moons every night no
i heard but what
the blood moons are every night the days
are only 20 minutes
you've got about three minutes before
the blood moon strikes are you [ __ ]
me
no i'm not [ __ ] you you gotta get in
a building
get upstairs it's 1600 get a weapon
get a weapon get upstairs tomorrow i
will come find you but tonight you're on
your own you understand me
i'm heading to a building man all right
go to a village
i told you this is going to be fun man
build some traps or something
barricade okay good luck
thanks man you too all right happy
birthday i'm really really happy that
we're doing this like this happy
birthday birthday
oh my god well you seem nervous you seem
nervous
wait i'm here i'm punching grass
[Laughter]
well that's not barricading your house
what are you doing i need materials
you need materials okay all right mr
material over that's us
my goal isn't to make a stone axe yet so
i can't craft one
[Laughter]
don't act yet stop i don't remember how
to craft
you're gonna be fine you're gonna be
fine man you're gonna be fine just
survive the night you'll be fine
stop saying it like that you'll be fine
you'll be fine
why would you be nervous what's there to
be nervous about blood moon every night
yeah i'm surrounded by gravestones
that's perfect for when you die
i mean when you live
do you have a gun no i don't i don't
have a gun what do you think i have a
guy i haven't gotten to a city yet how
would i have a gun
well what are you going to do tonight
die no i've got a i found an iron spear
oh god you lucky dog you oh man
on iron spear i've never heard of such
loot
look you're panicking the first rule is
not to panic
oh [ __ ] there's an angry man he's bald
like me and i know bald people are
scared
oh no he found me okay don't let them
find you
that's the first rule when they find you
that's when they kill you okay
not just scared mark i'm outside i'm not
barricaded is it okay
yeah sure yeah probably all right
blood moon's coming after this i'm gonna
make a dead sprint straight to you
don't die it's about to go down i'm not
ready it's about to go it's probably
i didn't find any all right fair enough
oh i can't punch it makes noise okay
well
noise don't matter on the blood moon
oh my god i'm so dead
you're fine just believe i fell
i told you not to panic
yeah but you said in a way that made me
panic more what that doesn't make any
sense
oh they're coming in oh god they're
coming
everything's fine oh [ __ ] they're coming
i don't have enough for this
oh they're at the door oh
they're at the door all right okay here
we go
let's go go down all right i got this i
got a bow
i'm fine oh good you had to lose all
inventory on
yeah i sure did i sure did great
oh they jumped right over that okay it's
fine
it's okay one down one down okay i see
where my
thingy is okay
i'm gonna survive i'm a survivor i'm a
survivor ow
i'm survivor baby i lived
all right coming to you baby uh i got a
tin can a feather and a block of wood
so uh i'm ready
[Music]
have you played with these settings
before yeah i got a lot of three days in
yeah
you got three nights in oh wait what i
was gonna keep going
i didn't want to spoil the experience
you okay yeah man i'm just checking this
car out
see if i can get uh some nails i got i
got four bucks
four bucks some nails and a tin can i'm
ready for the box
that's pretty good that was pretty good
maybe if i put the nails in the tin can
i shake it and throw it
on the strap to long i'm glad you're
enjoying this
you're enjoying this a lot no i'm just
i'm so scared it's i'm all alone
i was like okay we have a nice chill
start to this i need to talk to chad a
little bit
you did say it before we started like
yeah man i'm
just looking for something to relax dude
yeah you
why'd i let you make the game that was
my first and only mistake
i've never made another mistake in your
life besides
oh guard sent that a voice message what
did gar have to say
i'm in your house oh okay well he said
don't panic i'm in your house that's
good that's a good message
see when people say don't panic that's
when you don't panic oh it's dark again
it was just lighter dark it's just
before the dawn man don't you know how
that works oh great i'm glad we're
playing batman be
[ __ ] superman here okay i see light
of me and your sweet glory this is the
best birthday
i've ever had it's not your birthday
birthday i've ever had i will remember
this come your birthday
all right good news we're near uh we're
near some kind of a city
all right yeah that's not the one i died
in i don't know
you weren't that close before so i'm
assuming no i see a bed roll from where
you just came from
yeah i put a bed roll down ow oh god
ah [ __ ] bird oh the birds are the
freaking
worst i've never hated anything more
than the birds in this game
yeah that's what i felt too until i let
you make a game
i'm 700 meters away um oh
god the freaking i birds
like you deserve this i think it's like
if you have
feathers on you the birds are like or
eggs maybe it's eggs i don't know why
the birds are just demons it must be
eggs i'm gonna get rid of the eggs
well dad the birds it wasn't the egg
there's so many birds what me go away
birds why you why me i've had a rough
time too you know what have i done i'm
gonna die from
bird good thing i got this bandage here
i better use it this bird's hair too
oh god all right i'm almost there buddy
all right buddy uh 500 meters away buddy
all right buddy buddy you're gonna be
happy i increased xp gains so we got
xb out the wazoo you like wazoos wait
i'm infected
oh my god i got a thousand xp for
killing one that's great experience
i turned the xp gains up to give us an
advantage a lot
up do you hate do you hate me now
less all right i'll take it
i'll take it oh hey look the numbers are
red that means it's a blood
sir oh i saw a ghost
there was a man laying in the sun and i
went to check on him and he disappeared
oh
yeah i'm sure i'm sure i'm almost there
[ __ ] there's a bird kill did you make a
club or
kill the birds with a club they're in
the sky
hit em when they get close i don't know
do i need to do everything for you
yes if you're offering it's my birthday
[Laughter]
oh my bandage is gone because i lost my
inventory
yep you'll stop bleeding
[Laughter]
all right where are you where are you
there hey
looks like you found some nice boots
yeah yeah look at all these bird nests
you haven't touched
yeah come on birdiness i've been
busy dying nice goggles are those loot
bonus goggles
i just found them in that backpack over
there nice yeah so this house to the
west i was going to think about
all right let's do it let's do it you
and me you and me
i hate the desert all right i don't mean
to alarm you but it's 14 o'clock
and oh my jesus so just so you know
in this particular game time is a funny
thing hello
i really thought you were oh oh the
birds
and i'm helping i got it you're fine man
hello chica hi amy
amy says happy birthday thank you amy
amy said happy birthday you good man you
good oh god my screen 28 hell
why are you here take some here oh
here's some cream bars
hit the birds oh wait oh god what am i
doing here take this
a stun baton yeah somebody done thanks
man
you're welcome you know let me know if
you need anything else man
ow oh god coyote e
help help coyote i'm gonna get you gonna
get you
oh sweet
oh i missed it's serpentine oh piggy ah
don't touch the pit all right it's gone
don't let let it go
we need to go we need to get in this
building like now here oh
take this first yeah i gave you cream
not just aloe here take
take this i found it on the ground it's
probably good
all right it's back beat it's ass
what how how might want to let it go man
we're uh 16 30
16 30 my friend we haven't even cleared
out the building no we have not no
that's the thing yeah i have not
you got bows you got arrows i got 12
arrows
12 arrows how cheeky you doing girl all
right let's get to clearing
hello what sorry i'm here
yeah yeah oh [ __ ] me
what'd you do there was a surprise
[Laughter]
oh my that keeps happening they're just
always around the corner yeah they like
to do that yeah they
like to do that does this thing deal
damage what
the coyote it's dead i exploded its
brains
[Music]
you all right i'm good let's get in this
building i'm gonna trap up the door
here once you're inside are you which
way where are you
you go oh i was breaking a wall down i
was breaking a wall down
where were you breaking a wall down uh
over here at the door at the door
one door oh hey mark hi
god damn it all right team
wade coming at ya
whoa teamwork
hey that thing dropped loot oh
oh surprise behind you i got it
i shot it in the ass you're doing great
you're doing great man all right well
done
my friend my buddy here you can loot
that guy
there's some loot there i'm building
some traps i'm gonna trap
up the front door i'm gonna build a door
i'm gonna trap it up
dude we're gonna survive you me
we're survivors well my thighs are nice
and protected
good thighs are the most important part
to protect yeah
everyone knows that i know that you know
that we know that
literally everybody knows that right
buddy
yeah um there's no upstairs this is just
a death floor it seems
no no no no no no you picked this
building it's a good building
i would not want to live in a world
where you didn't pick a good building
there's a coffin sure is
buddy sure is this steel armor schematic
forged schematic motorcycle you got the
ford schematic
i sure did hell yeah my dude okay that
door is trapped up
how's the front looking you didn't build
a door
no that's fine that's good actually
that's fine one way in
no ways out we're gonna survive you
me that zombie over there we're gonna
live
right buddy i'm good who are you
what you're not even paying attention to
me are you
oh yeah something's breaking down your
your thing
my wall my impenetrable fortress
all right bows at the ready oh it wasn't
even the blood moon
no it wasn't even the blood oh god damn
it
look it's fire it's fine it's not gonna
be that many right away
we just uh oh that's a lot of footsteps
ah all they did was change the type of
wood
loser good thing we're not shooting them
we're so dead no we're [ __ ] we're
starting but they gotta get through that
and then the one below it
they're never gonna get through all
right ready
oh i'm aimed i feel like oh god oh god
it's so many
it's not that many my ass it's fine it's
fine they gotta get through the other
one
it's a shooting gallery somehow i think
i've missed every shot it's like fishing
fish in a barrel
easy peasy this is how we do
i got it no they're not we you me
we're survivors
feels good to survive not good luck i'm
out of arrows that's okay
pick some of those stuff we got there oh
you good girl
chico is a good girl
there you go don't bother helping me
break down the obstacle in your path
just uh i didn't have any wood to repair
my ex
which is not yet broken oh so you had no
excuse
to be honest no i didn't i tried to make
it sound like
it did not work no it didn't you really
undermined it came out in the end
i was gonna believe you like up until
that last part of the sentence
that's where your story kind of fall
apart yeah oh
damn my honesty yeah damn your honesty
man
so what i've discovered is on blood
moons once the horde stops coming you're
good for the night
unfortunately later on then they come
until the end of the night how long's
later on like day 40
i don't know i only got to day three
with blood moon every night so i don't
know if it scales like
someone so later on is tonight yeah
later on
what do you mean of course we pay
attention blood moons every night come
on keep up keep up man
keep keep up are we making this our uh
our uh housy home
it's pretty horrible yeah yeah it is
it is not the best but but but i i've
literally never seen worse
but we could but actually you know i it
does kind of seem like a good
kill box if we only fill up the floor
all right i'm gonna do something i'm
gonna make an executive decision i'll
say we'll live here for a bit
but to make this house more a home i've
got some tricks up my sleeve
um why is it dark again oh that's right
it's always darker before the dawn
wow is that a me impression is that
convincing
not at all are you drunk no hello
hello oh i killed him what are you
talking about
deep water you okay man
i'm thirsty you having a good time you
enjoyed seven days tonight
i'm alive okay good good man good very
good
all right so we're gonna go into town
okay
i'm just trying to get some wood i'm
following you you need wood how much
wood you need
oh no i've got some now i need water
i'll make you a yucca juice you know how
to make yucca juice
i yeah yeah are you just saying yeah or
do you actually know
i do i type in yuck and then it appears
in my bar and i make yucca juice
yeah if you got water i don't
you're not making all right drink the
water or the juice if i don't have the
water
well here here here uh here's a yucca
it's hot
it's hot man so hot
this is a good juice thanks man squeezed
it myself
i don't like that all right so we're
just gonna just like
let's hunt around if you find some good
stuff holler if you get in trouble with
zombies
scream louder okay okay there's corn we
could plant some corn that's food right
yeah we can start a little farm
you like farms i bet you do you're
almost dead
what happened to the pain killers i gave
you do those give you health
yes but they make you thirsty
yeah you sure did hey but would you
rather be thirsty or would you rather be
healthy
i need water so bad yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah i found a house smart
footage
okay special house what do you mean what
makes it special
i can't get in it i found a way in
there's a secret in the roof
oh good good work found a lot of useful
recipes why can't i search this desk
please just be dead ever
i don't know how those are misses are
you dead
not twice if you're dead why am i trying
to hit you with my axe
that's a good question i don't know bad
bad plan
you're right bad plan good thing i'm so
good at
killing things no don't ah god damn it
i just scrapped my axe i don't know why
oh toilet please have water
[ __ ] slurp the poopy water
wade i would have i'm sad
[Laughter]
why is there one why is this door
barricade on the second floor
i do sound pretty intoxicated like 90
percent
finding pistol ammo which means that a
pistol can't be too far behind my friend
is that true i'm thirsty can you stop
talking about how thirsty you are and
just
hold off for a bit okay okay buddy
hey buddy oh god oh god oh god please do
not make me bleed
oh yeah oh surprise [ __ ] were
you about to say make
were you about to cheer on the zombie
that was i feel like you were about i
feel like you were hello
hi okay hi amy oh
no please we're killing weight
apparently good job
don't oh i'm bleeding and i'm infected
and i'm done don't
do any of that wade don't do you put
down your bed roll right you put down a
bedroom
you would definitely have done that
before we go out on an adventure right
sorry mark i'm distracted thank you
thank you people for all the amazing
my connection to you is very bad at the
moment uh you hear this
static man
i found some poopy water for you hey
don't worry i got your poopy water
oh good i put down a bed roll just now
okay good we're
in a dangerous house of death oh i love
dangerous house of death
why can't i swing i'm out of stamina
that happens
yes i'm gonna bleed out don't do that
wade oh
it's not even the blood moon way i can't
help you if you can't survive
there's so much the stamina really effed
me of not having water
god and stop talking about thirsty or
i'm gonna bring back water and just take
some time
i fell in a hole oh god i'm so doomed
i'm so doomed it it really boned me yeah
see sometimes bad things just happen
i got dazed do not believe me i'm
bleeding oh god oh god
why are you fast now hang in there i'm
fine
i'm fine i got it i got it that's my
words of advice
ow ow i survived through my wits by
keeping calm
i survived all right we're back in the
business
back in the business and what is that
business wade
[ __ ] people death like murder
it got worse it's got
the worse of [ __ ] people to death
sometimes people just want to go out a
certain way and i offer that
[Laughter]
i found bullets yep finding a lot of
bullets not a lot of guns
oh medical supplies please have nitrate
powder sweet i don't get
why sometimes they go faster
sometimes they go faster it's like if
you hit them with an arrow occasionally
they'll get angry
and i don't get that i found the
motherlode
i don't have an axe wait i need a stone
please come get me a
one rock oh yeah okay
i'm gonna go away water never mind mark
sorry good luck i'll be there later what
do you mean
give me a rock i need a rock i don't
have a rock yeah i gotta redo some stuff
make sure i get this uh water
okay i'll punch this you matter your
life matters to me i'm on my way right
now
i got it i got rock you suck dicks
i got rock i do i suck them till people
die
that's what you do that's your specialty
got it all right
i everybody has something special mine
is
murder sucking murder sucking they call
me the murder sucker
who's breaking and entering i'm breaking
something are you growling and breaking
in
no sure wish i had a gun there's a gun
safe here
that i would be able to open if i had
lock picks who
killed this man who killed this man
one lock pick what's the odds that i'm
going to be able to get into this
safe with uh one lock pick very low um
i got a pistol did you get in with one
lock pick no i found something else in
another box
that had a pistol so guess who's got a
pistol
i'm just sucking ass here and say you
it's me
it's me wow i can't believe i put did
that math
good mommy dude my god all right one
lockpick here we go baby here we go
strap that scrap that i believe in this
this is though
this is the lock pick all right it's 18
15. we should get back
once i get in this safe and find the oh
my god this one lock pick oh the one
lock pick did it
oh i have the goods my friend
my friend guess who's got the goods
i'm gonna do the math here and say you i
do
i do have the goods my friend
i got to come back into this house to
get the basement mark but the the main
floor
you know indeed yes
i know what you're talking about yeah i
know what you're talking about all right
time to head
home dude there's so much loot here i
left my
bedroll here why did you put the bed
roll there of all places
oh i just figured you know best always
have it close-by
i've got a gun for you and i've got a
gun for me you are going to be a happy
camper oh yeah buddy boy
okay okay but and you know in fact i
think i even got a repair kit so i'm
gonna i'll repair it for you first
and then i'm gonna bring it to you hey
which way is our house is it
south or west uh i don't
know and i don't remember how to get out
of here your bed roll will point you in
the right direction
yeah but i'm not outside yet okay let's
do southwest
i've got guns for you man i am
very overburdened oh my god i need to
get home
yeah south you said southwest it's the
church it's literal it's a church
on a hill directly south for me okay
then that's that's all right mark the
birds
that's your problem man that's your
problem
that's your problem you deserve that
you're gonna love me it doesn't have a
lot of ammo so make your shots count but
i can't pick that up until we do we have
a box yeah there's there's chests over
here yeah i also got a junk turret
for whenever we get that going okay do
you have stone can you make a campfire i
got some dirty water oh here's some
regular water
yeah yeah i can okay we better hurry 10
minutes until i make what do you
what do you need to do in 10 minutes uh
forget about it
just piss your pants i don't care which
way they're coming from
uh a good question i think this way
i think i hear him yep i hear they're
coming in all right
i just don't want to be soggy why am i
okay close the door god damn it close
the door closer
okay uh can you help what are you doing
i
don't want to be soggy cause my
inventory is full you don't need to get
fast to shoot
oh i didn't reload mark oh my god i'm
gonna die
there see you got him you're just
shooting our door
oh no you got it there's a gap i see i
see smart smart that's uh by design
so i always go for the boobs i don't
know why the boobs are the weak point
gonna try to reinforce this door there
we go
gotta reload seems a lot more than last
night yeah it seems to go up
exponentially i wonder why you only made
it through three nights
look at your armor you're looking snazzy
thanks man you too you got legs you got
you got your nice goggles i do have legs
thank you
oh i found goggles too that's right oh i
got you some goggles hold on no i found
some
oh they're better though what no i found
some look look at the color of these
though
oh those are nice but they don't give
nearly as good a loot bonus
unfortunately loot bonus yeah
lucky goggles they give you a loot bonus
but isn't that why you put on the lucky
goggles
did you just put them on because they
were an item and you found it and you
were like
hey anything's better than nothing and
you put it on you didn't know why
yes here i found you a hood take
take the leather
did you make a campfire can you make a
campfire please on it
i'll get you some nice murky water once
you do
like all for you buddy there you go
perfect
you know you the man oh that's what they
say
that's what they say are cooking up some
murky water
hmm well the chest appears to be very
full
there's another chest right next to it
oh baby sorry i was just very i get very
excited when i
use a chest yeah well you always do aim
for the boobs i've heard that about you
i always always go for the boobs
something i've always been respectful
about you about
i know you love that thank you i'm glad
we're equally good at being bad at
talking
what are you talking about who talk you
to be
yeah what you taku to be solo
we're always on the same page you and i
always on the same page
i once built a bicycle oh you know
tell me it was it had two wheels
yeah had storage too it's pretty sweet
is it a game or irl
oh in-game all right well how would i
even do that i don't even know the first
thing about bicycles
that guy's burning i shouldn't waste
bullets
why is it so hot it's we're in the
desert ya dingus
yeah but it's like hotter than normally
hot we're
in the desert
[Music]
i'm gonna sip this water and feel much
better for a couple seconds
you feel sick to your stomach and have
diarrhea did you drink poopy water
no just regular water oh it can still
give you a
dysentery yep so you got really unlucky
it's only like a three percent chance
this game does not like you man
so what i just randomly sh that's
literally an ass [ __ ] is the thing
yeah i know you're gonna be real thirsty
that gives you real dehydration
oh my god i've got golden i said
something about goldenrod i've got
goldenrods up here
okay yeah you you drinking rods dude
drink the golden rods
they're not drinkable well you gotta you
gotta make a golden rod tea out of it is
the thing
oh [ __ ] dude you're doing great i
believe in you
oh aim for the dick just aim for the
dick just aim for the dick got him
nicely done man one good dick shot
that's all it took
that hooks you you are the the murderer
[ __ ]
the dick master dick dick master that
was it hey the uh the golden rod is gone
so i'm just
[ __ ] all right cool anyway there was
absolutely nothing worth having in this
house
are you glad you went back i went to a
different house why would i go back to
the same house oh
i'm in the same house because i didn't
finish looting this one this one's kind
of a crazy house
who took my golden rod how are you not
dead
ah you all right i got surprise
[ __ ] slapped you need to not do that
bam i love shotgun oh
there was a surprise in the cabinet why
why
i found eleven poopy water wade i think
you're going to be very happy
so wade you gotten any new uh new
birthday wishes new goals this year
new goals yeah make it to next year i
guess oh
come on you gotta have a bigger goal
than that you're 31.
30. 31. wow making it to next year's a
pretty
pretty big one i mean i guess
i am still taking shits everywhere well
stop
you're pooping out all your water clean
plain weighted head mod baseball bat
parts and 222
thanks grandpa 220
oh yes please all right i'm gonna
i'm gonna go for that airdrop it's
actually not i am full up on items god
damn it
that seems like a good idea to go for it
oh no it doesn't never bird
bird oh god i missed with the shotgun
point playing out does that even happen
i hate the birds you can be attacked by
birds again
i don't know what causes the birds to go
crazy they just swoop in from out of
town
papi has so many saves mark how many
lock picks you have i might need
lock pick back up i've got one okay i've
got
two left i got oh happy
happy you made it a tricky safe come on
come on come on yes
give me a gun knives you
have a gun well i know but more guns
equals more safety
more safety if i find guns in this air
drop
i will give you one i'm out of lock
picks now there's one more safe left
wait how many safes were in one building
three
that i found so far what there's still a
whole basement mark this place is huge
where did you go a special house that
you can only get in through either by
breaking into like the garage or
climbing up the
scaffolding on the wall are you kidding
me it's on the roof
where is it it says it's right on the
roof i do not see
you're right there it's right there
all right minecraft's out baby
yeah did you find a way up oh i did
well i built the way up oh not a single
goddamn gun are you kidding me
was there anything at least good i got a
workbench schematic
and a rad counter schematic and a knife
and
uh
yay that was a worthless worthless thing
damn it pappy you're safe broke four
lock picks
pappy don't like you i don't know how to
tell you this
no no papi dude happy do what pappy do
and patrick
like me i'm waiting for someone to be a
someone something surprise
it's your surprise what does that mean
it means it's hot what is i
found the place okay what is it it's
guns
i found a gun store box mark i got a
double barrel shotgun
a junk turret a hunting rifle iron chest
armor
i also have found all of these things i
just want you to know i'm only i'm still
in the same house
i don't understand what house you went
to i found tea it can cure your
dysentery
it's almost gone but i would take it all
right little ungrateful
uh very grateful thank you i found
steroids i'm injecting them into my ass
i'm coming home wade you must have found
the good
[ __ ] i found the best [ __ ]
yeah i still have not finished searching
this one house how
how big is that house i looked there
were not big houses
there were not that many houses and
they didn't look that big this house is
cray-cray okay sure whatever you say bud
bud
that house does not look that big
there's no way there's that many saves
in there
by the way i i am going back home are
you you've gone i'm working my way out
of this house it takes a long time to
leave
i don't believe you not a word you say i
don't believe any of it
i got mark i played dead by daylight
yesterday as part of like a charity
stream incentive yeah
and uh i was doing my i was doing elmo
voice
and i had to sneeze and i made the worst
mistake i've ever made in my life
i thought to myself you know probably
really cute to hear elmo sneeze let me
let me do my voice impression while i
sneeze
i thought i broke my nose it hurt so bad
whatever i did like like whatever you do
for that like blocks part of your
passages
so the sneak like my nose just started
gushing i thought it was bleeding
but it was just like saliva or something
i don't know whatever whatever i did
it was the worst decision i ever made it
hurt so bad i really thought i broke my
nose
i don't know how you break your nose
doing an impression but that's
that's so very you that yeah
i do not doubt it at all that's
hilarious i dislocated my thumb play
animal crossing
what i don't believe you i got
notifications
miss you i don't believe you how did you
do that i wouldn't believe me if it
wasn't me
okay i got an iron mask i got this i've
got a
brass knuckle i've got uh a
pistol here for you what is this helmet
it's an iron helmet you look great shut
up look it's gonna protect you why
why are you complaining oh no man how do
i equip the brass knuckles let's put
them in a slot yeah it's what do you
mean just like any other
weapon all right get ready got get your
gun out god damn it all right wade
thanks i forgot oh i don't want any
bullets for this pistol
oh my god you don't have any nine
millimeter in your adventures in
grandpa's glorious house
it's fine we're gonna be fine yep yeah
we're only 40 minutes into it
oh my god i'm gonna run out of bullets
that's it we're already done
no no there's one more oh two more three
more
i've not been shooting i know i've
noticed
well we shouldn't both be wasting them
on the same zombies i gotta reload
coming
good work all right you shoot we'll do
it strategically when you reload i'll go
good stuff good stuff good stuff
reloading
good work good working work check that
loot bag it looks good looks like good
that's a good loot bag
there's a lot of zombies yeah it doesn't
i mean it doesn't sound good out there
we're gonna need some better defenses
real soon
yeah i'm almost done with that house man
since i've been in that house you betcha
it's gonna be good i don't believe
you're ever gonna be done with that
house
no it's just the basement the kitchen
left that's it and oh dogs
door is kind of breaking i am out of
pistol ammo moving to shotgun and i'm
just going to close range kablams
all right
damn son i've got so many skill points
waiting to be spent
same i've not spent hardly any of them
good to know we're playing this game
right my dude
yep yep i've been busy that one house
over the house you betcha i'm gonna get
on those skill points
this mythical house all right come see
it's nuts my objective for the next day
is just to beef up our defenses
give us something to work with you know
yeah you know what i mean dude i know
what you mean
this is the best building we could have
possibly defended with by the way
whoo we are gonna if we don't find like
a bajillion bullets tomorrow
we're screwed i think we're clear oh
here's your golden rod if you wanna
get rid of your diarrhea i am very
infected have you found any antibiotics
no okay we do eventually need to get to
the trader as well
because the trader gives antibiotics is
like a reward for
stuff i'm gonna leave all right goodbye
check my statistics
let me check my star thai steaks i just
scrapped my food
unscrap it quick wherever you just grab
your
food i didn't even know you could scrub
you scrapped your food what is wrong
with you
look i gave us a challenge i didn't know
that you would be your own
biggest obstacle here
you scrapped your food
ah right you know it's fine you know
it's fine
listen we all make mistakes sometimes my
mistake was scrapping my food
yep you're right you right about that
all right so buddy buddy buddy what i'm
discovering is
this platform not gonna do us any good
all right all right
because it limits our options to trap
them
and doesn't allow us to get good fire
lines so
i'm gonna get rid of it okay you hear me
i approve
you do approve i know you do i know
buddy
keep it up i will focus on making this a
fortress of impenetration we're going to
finish this house today
okay if you find bullets bring them back
we're going to need a lot of them
oh yeah do you have a lockpick i meant
to take your lockpick yeah take my
lockpicks
i'm gone oh okay you're not that far
back all right oh i stepped on a cactus
wait if you leave it like that can they
still get up
no they not the jump up i'm not gonna
leave it like that
yeah maybe they could have gotten up we
would have been safe forever no it's not
about
keeping them no we would what no no
[ __ ] anymore
great oh mark minnie mob mini mob mini
mob
minnie mob i don't like the sound of
minnie mob where's minniemob oh
there's there's they're right outside
the door i see okay okay
i got a sniper rifle watch this all
right oh i gotta reload
watch this yep oh oh i found a cactus
you are the best i missed
we are the just a pair aren't we there
we go nice hit oh that guy
is scarier oh maybe don't stand next to
them what are you
doing i'm bleeding oh you're bleeding
why didn't you just look at him approach
you
uh i was trying to save you some bullets
i'm gonna punch him
why all right mark he's coming hit me
oh my god wade you're good you're on
your own
all right you're doing great man i'm on
him one shot what what [ __ ]
vicious yeah he's very violent i can
tell
he doesn't nearly kills me all right
back to business man
enough with the games come on hey we
gotta survive here
all right as soon as i've done this
house i believe
we're not gonna survive the night man
cool down make yooka juice
yucca yeah yucky juice oh what am i
doing i've got a bajillion points
i'm doing the stupid thing oh yeah i
have 13 points
the penetrator that sounds like me more
loot
better loot better lock picking what do
i need perception
five it's all for the greater good man
all right perception seven i'm just
going for loot i'm gonna be a looter
all right did you put all of your points
in looting
yes no combat points no exactly zero
but i am maxed out on lucky looter and
i'm a very good lock picker
all right you know actually that's fine
if that's gonna be your specialty
then that's good when you start finding
like level five level six guns
we will be in business business i just
went for it i went for it dude
i love that about you did i get those
lock picks from you i did
thank you i cannot promise that you
picked them up honestly
at this point i'm really wondering in my
inventory so they're either yours or i'm
just i'm lucky maybe the lucky loader is
already coming in handy
really one or the other it could be
anything at this point all right good
luck to you
see you back home yes
the last lock pick we got it and i got a
steel spear
i'm infected still by the way just so
you should know
i'm looking i'm looking for meds man
i've not found any for you but i'm
looking hard did you find some for
yourself
no i died so i cured myself oh right oh
that's right the perfect
cure the ultimate cure as some might say
yeah death is definitely it's oh i oh my
god i found a crucible i just
found a crucible nice dude
i think actually it's your loot like
your lucky looters
is legitimately helping a cigar
you want a cigar dude i've never wanted
anything more in my life all right
i'll bring it home to you i know you're
going to die soon
you're very sick i mean you write about
that
oh thanks man thank you
always looking out for me aren't you if
it's your dying wish to have that cigar
you'll have it buddy i mean it wasn't
but
not my dying wish but i preach the
thought
oh there's another doer the laundry room
nothing in the washing machine how many
rooms
are in this house this is mark you've
got to come see this house
i don't want to i don't believe it
exists i believe it's a trick to
make me look at your penis and i will
not be fooled again
did you find ammo
maybe 20. uh just so you know 20
we're at 20. mark i just found a sit a
secret room in a basement
we should poof here this place is so
good okay well great we'll do it
tomorrow get your ass back here
working on it buddy full speed ahead to
call me full speed
susie are you back yet oh
no i'm very far oh my god is this the
right way
what do you mean is this the right way
oh let's go the wrong way
[Applause]
i can't well actually if they split up i
might actually be able to survive on my
own
so stay away go away this is my home
i'm almost back don't worry dude hurry i
just need you to cover me while i empty
my mind you are going to die i do not i
am so dead
you are better hurry my god why are you
not
hurrying you are not going nearly fast
oh my god you are going to i'm going to
watch
you die cover me can you jump oh my god
they're coming for you i'm out of
stamina
you save it save it and then get over
here
get in get in get in get in get in okay
guys
give me ammo what do you mean you said
you found something
no no i said i might have but i didn't
wait then you did
don't say you might have this is a nice
looking place you got here
thank you help defend it yeah
i'm i'm trying i'm defending to the
right mark my guns broke
that's not good man do we have a weapon
repair kit
uh yes i do actually here i'm dropping
them
repair your stuff oh i got concussed
they're bringing it up the they're
coming up
okay back up back up to the second stage
get through the door okay that's a lot
of them
there's a lot of them can i have some of
those repair kits back i'm going to go
pop a a couple heads real quick yeah
there you go
all right i'm going to just do the
strategy of just you wait popping out
i'm going to finish that house you
you're wait no you cannot
be serious you were you've been at that
house for five days
i'm almost done no that's not how houses
work
i clear like two houses a day if i'm
this
is a special house there's no way i do
not believe you
where are they heading you gotta come
with me you gotta check out this house
i'm not gonna check out this house
because it doesn't exist
crazy you are literally sitting in the
basement of this house because you have
not brought anything
back so i don't believe that it actually
exists
i'm going back to that wait mark i named
my inventory i'm coming back but
the slowest crawl back i've ever seen
uh man i'm gonna need more iron if i'm
gonna shore up these defenses again
i mean this is a good little choke point
i like it but
it suffered in the night yeah that
worked uh it worked really well
yeah it really suffered okay okay i
tossed a couple i made another chest and
put on the floor next to your other one
okay thank you yeah no problem
teamwork teamwork dreamworks tomorrow
i'm actually gonna put out the junk
turret and i'm gonna have it blasting
some of these
goons okay all right break team break go
yep mark here comes this house it's a
great house no i i do not believe this
house
we're gonna die oh hey buddy this house
is right here
the house is right in front of you not
the white house wait there's nothing
there
no it's real wait what there's no house
happy left me so many locks
papi what are you talking about man
happy
pappy's been dead for 20 years
yeah i know but he left me he left me
some good luck surprises
this is the dream sequence as you slowly
actually i didn't know what was
happening but i was just letting it go
no happy please say it so
all right it's secret basement room time
i'm finally here after all this time
no i don't believe it it's finally time
i don't believe it a weapons bag a
reinforced
chest look at this stuff you cannot make
me believe this
messiah sealed shipping crate how
many things were in that place oh my god
there's working stiff sealed shipping
crates on the way oh
he's lying he's lying everybody great
guys someone said mark my entire stream
vaude
and i will i'll watch every second of it
i got
an iron door a wire tool an engine
level five pistol level five stun baton
no
it's not true you know it to be true
dude you're looking for
movie viewing history i'm actually very
glad you've gotten like lucky looter in
that stuff
because that is gonna come in super
handy yeah i got a level five pistol to
give you
hell yeah all right i'm done searching
this house there wasn't much here
[Music]
yeah it doesn't even make me mad that's
funny that's dead now that's funny
that's funny right there i don't care
who you are that's funny it's a pretty
good house
pretty good house
if i was a basement i'd motorboat this
basement i'd [ __ ] it you'd [ __ ] it to
death wouldn't you
you sick bastard oh yeah you would you
know
it oh yeah to death you ever regret the
things
we say in public only whenever people
quote them back to me like
i see i've got like really selective
memory apparently because like i'll say
something horribly crazy insane
offensive
or sexual and i'll completely like in
two seconds i've forgotten it came out
of my mouth
and then like someone will send me a
clip that i'm like oh my god i'm a potty
mouth monster
i'm a spotty mouth monster i got a real
no no lips oh no you know the whole wave
on youtube and stuff did not curse so
much
it really passed us right by didn't it
yeah
i used to not curse at all i don't know
how i did it yeah i don't either
especially around me and bob eventually
eventually i changed
yeah you changed you changed me i miss
all the way
bird what's hitting me bird oh god
bird bird love wasting two shotgun
shells
i found a water purifier mod do that put
that in your helmet any water consumed
while installed in your helmet
yeah put it in your helmet you can drink
even poop water oh my god i will
i put 121 9 mil 20 shotgun shells and a
level 5 pistol
love that level 4 double barrel shotgun
i love everything you're saying
uh an iron door a level 5 stun baton oh
my god say it's slower
[Music]
i'm over it
all right i'm just gonna hit a few more
trees and i'll be back and i'll try to
double up the defenses as much as i can
when are we gonna get a better place
than the church actually the church is
good because it's so wide
that the zombies only ever come to the
front of it so it does kind of funnel
them down which is nice
yeah it's been surprisingly good so far
just considering how
shitty it kind of looks i guess it's
easy to defend because there's only like
one way they've been coming in which is
nice that's exactly what i just
said okay so what do we what do you want
done defense wise
do you want more wood spike traps like
what can i do to actually help well what
i'm doing is
i'm just kind of like layering the
barbed wire traps i have
okay i don't think i can make barbed
wire ones i've i that's what i was doing
i was getting metal so that i could make
more
uh just oh i put a bunch of scrap metal
inside you can there's tons of iron in
there
i got plenty i'm good okay the weird
thing about the junk turd is you have to
be close enough to it or it won't work
we have to be close enough to it yeah
that's that's the weird thing about it
what if it's right there would that work
oh i didn't reload it
it's like no don't
shoot it god damn it yeah pipes place
that would work
let's clear them off just found a
crucible cause i remember how expensive
that was
i just found a crucible isn't that crazy
yeah can you make a forge we could use
that
i need clay and i need lots of stone i
need 60 clay and 50 stones oh
and leather do we have leather i've not
killed any animals i have not killed any
animals
there's three leather so i need seven
more leather well we'll get it next time
then
oh yeah it's already nighttime yep ammo
might be the problem tonight cause i've
got three extra clips for this
okay well hopefully uh with the number
of layers i have and the junk turret
will help a bit
i'm just gonna go ahead and i'll i'll
i'm just gonna triple up the layers yes
get up wayne i was having some issues
nice
i need to drink my yucca your yucca
oh yeah i didn't get any drinks
yeah junkie junkie baby look
at the junkie go
get them junkie
they're really getting caught up on the
barbed wire which is good oh hell yeah
oh this is great
yeah it's starting to get up there's one
peekaboo
dude that worked out great i think the
junk's out of ammo
yeah at the wall over here uh watch that
one's about to jump up here
yep i'm down to my last 24 bullets
okay one jumped up um whoa
so they're definitely primarily coming
from that right side they were the other
night too
yeah they're rounding the corner
we're almost through maybe i don't know
man blood moon every night huh whose
idea was that
it's good for experience it's awful
for everything else oh jesus
it's fine got it good
god it's so many of them
uh oh ow
i couldn't even shoot because i should
sneak attack it
i can't get her ah
uh four bullets all right back up let's
go inside
let's go inside let's start poking them
through the gap i guess would be
the best move i'm gonna crouch down here
[Applause]
i don't have any wood i can't remember
for that
it's just people caught on the edges i
think we're good after this all right
that worked out nicely
those traps uh just a gosh darn delight
the amount of good [ __ ] i get even just
off of a dead zombie is about
yeah you know actually i'll let you lose
you loot everything
there's only one thing to loot but i got
it all right
um okay so here's my thought
okay you listening you listen i'm
listening yeah i'm here
we here's what we do all right we grab
the best stuff we got okay
okay okay you listen you hearing me i
already hate this
we go to the trader we
sell some of the best stuff get better
stuff
okay you hear me you hearing me you hear
me okay
get better stuff and then okay
follow me follow me follow me build a
better base okay you hear me you hear me
okay how far is the traitor from here
1.6
1.3 you're you've got a closer one okay
good good
good to know good to know you got a
closer one so you're saying we're not
coming back here
i s i don't think so all right we should
get going though
so you can you you lead the way because
you
your trader is going to be closer than
my trader straight north
straight north oh rip cigar you didn't
we didn't take the cigar
oh you didn't grab the cigar
you were supposed to be having it
equipped that was your cigar was my
cigar what are you talking about
i forgot that for you i thought it was
for i thought it was for a special
occasion and i was saving it for yeah
the special occasion was we lived more
than three days and smoke it
well it's the seventh day and this game
is called
seven days to die so we're gonna die
tonight
i'm i'm just looting on the way because
like i just get such good [ __ ]
yeah you loot you loot you loot all you
want
my inventory is very full though it's
not good chicken
bam we did any food
yes meats
i've got meat whoa there's a big tree in
the distance what the hell that tree's
huge you need to head
north now it looks like all the trees
are huge
that's the traitor i hate to say this
we're going to get to the trader and
we're going to be caught with our pants
down
we are we are dead
no no no no no no wait did you grab the
chainsaw right i did yes i have the
chainsaw
yes i'm not stupid
you've left the cigar what yes
because i knew you'd go back oh no it's
the [ __ ] guy
you're not bringing counterfeit money in
here are you you're not bringing
counterfeit money in here
are you no you stupid idiot
oh i didn't get bartering i didn't know
no it's fine it's fine it's fine i
didn't either
it's fine i i got one one point in
bartering five percent better it's fine
it's all good selling all of our best
stuff is the right play right now yep
sure am
sell it all sell sell sell
because we're gonna be bye bye bye in a
second
state your business fool that's what he
said
yeah he's kind of a douche kind of a
dick what do you got what do you got
buddy a bit he's got he's got a mini
bike
oh [ __ ] that seems useful i could
definitely run away from the
zombies with that what you wouldn't
leave me well i never said leave you
i never said leave you mark we have like
five minutes before
he doesn't have any ammo does he he has
got
nothing i'm going to buy his gun powder
out but
he's got it dead he's got nothing all
right to the house get to a house
oh i got to sell oh why won't you sell
uh there's a there's like a church
there's some walls on this church
we have good luck with the church i need
to grab some wood on the way
should i still i don't want to sell this
engine dude i don't think so
why did a tree just fall on me because i
i don't know why it fell on you but i
cut it down all right my friend
do you trust me hmm
all right yes good because i
know the way to victory the only reason
you didn't get that mini bike is because
it was too expensive
you're right okay look i admit it but
listen listen oh my god that one of us
is inherently more valuable to keep it
alive than the other it's just a fact
no what no it's me what are you talking
about i'm the expert here
expert i'm leaving all right yeah you
come come to me
it's set up all right trust me
okay i'm on my way it's up why wouldn't
it be that's what i've been doing
really hope it's safe over here cause we
got three minutes before [ __ ]
gets wacky why would that be pointing
that way burn
why is my stamina [ __ ] food
i don't have any of that well eat some
food what's wrong with you do you
have any of that why don't you why don't
you have any it sounds like a you
problem i'm falling
perfect bedroll bed roll right
right bedroll right that's not what i
wanted um
god why can't i not get up this thing
perfect
perfect i might not place the bedroll
but oh my god
the locals seem nice i'm up mark how far
north west did you go
very not uh just follow my arrow you see
my arrow just follow my arrow
yeah i'm falling we have two minutes and
i'm out of stamina no
what no stop
i heard that it sounded not close enough
it's all good man on a scale of one to
oh god oh god oh god how [ __ ] are we
oh god not
at all
is this the house don't say it like that
of course
it's beautiful strong bold
brash get up the the side the ladder i
put on the side i didn't tell you about
the ladder on the side but there's a
ladder on the side if you're not going
on the inside or no outside on the side
on the outside oh why did you put the
ladder in the furthest possible side
well i didn't it was from the closest to
the trader what do you mean the furthest
possible side it was exactly the side it
needed to be on
where's this ladder wait a minute where
the left is on the side of the house
the south side come back here on the
south side
look you jump up the the bricks i put
into the blocks all right take the
blocks before okay okay
good there now climb up the the very
straight
just climb up the ladder and stop
complaining what
we're safe we're safe
my friend that's they're just vultures
they ain't gonna get nobody we on the
other hand
will never be got cause we're safe
s is for such a beautiful
birthday a is for any
time f is for friends like you
and me and he is for eat
my eyes oh
safe oh safe
we're so safe in this place
i love you and you love me and
we are safe
this is the worst song i've ever heard
in my life
just wait till you hear my rendition of
happy birthday
no oh happy happy birthday happy happy
birthday it's happy day for you
and a happy day for wade happy happy
happy happy birthday
you got born i did get born
you're not wrong hey there's meds over
there oh there's a chest
yeah let me loot it i got it oh i looted
it oh yeah i forgot you
i forgot the best thing
here i mean there's two level fives so
maybe it's still counted i don't think
well that's a lot of dudes oh
man wade it's fun there's like two
oh not out there you mean here
yep right here right here baby look at
all this experience we're getting
we're rich how do i only have 24 bullets
i don't know well i got a pokey stick if
they get too close
yeah yeah that's what we need i got
chainsaw if they get too close
take some of that hey it's working
up did you fall oh my god wait how did
you accomplish that
mark i made mistakes wow
i fell all right fair enough it happens
to the me
yeah it sure does man it really happens
to the you
uh i'm gonna go get a drink i'm gonna
keep i'm gonna get a drink
you you got it man we are safe
we're safe we are safe
all right man um happy birthday
mark don't let him get me all right that
looks awful
like they're gonna get me oh god what
happened i thought you were watching
oh i have a gun i forgot hold on ow
oh my good god okay
hey so when they fall they just break
their way back in again
yep but hey now we've got our
permanently safe base
that no one could break into right
yeah i got six bullets left well that's
good
all right time to grow greet the day
what there's a lot of
baby yeah i know right
it's their way of saying happy birthday
let's just get out and buy now they're
all slow because it's the morning
you know what i mean that dog ain't slow
now
mark is the construction
he's not slow some of them are fast i
guess
how is he still alive all right good
well done proud of you
very proud we need loot go
get it you're the loot guy my
inventory's full well we need a
base have no ammo um
all right i guess i'm looting with one
open block how many do i have well
put your stuff away or sell it how why
are you full
put it away oh hey i didn't put my
sleeping bag down mark oh i didn't
either
well better do that as don't wanna don't
be caught with our pants down
i'm gonna have to go back to using a bow
i should have
locked i should have put more points in
archery oh you jump
oh you jump no you jump don't you you
jump
oh oh surprise
it's a shy surprise cream cream cream
cream cream cream cream cream cream
you okay man i creamed i'm good that
doesn't suck
yeah just doesn't sound as bad as you
[ __ ] them to death but you know as
long as you cream down the way
bows do not do a lot bows are a
real wimpy guy my guy my dude
oh this house was just unlocked okay
oh oh no oh i keep getting surprised
stop getting surprised i don't want to
mean
why didn't i put any points in the
weaponry oh yeah you didn't did you
no i told you i put a big fat
zero i was like wait you need
perch yeah but then you liked you're
like oh babe
that was that's me cement mixer
schematic that seems really useful
i mean if we want cement sure
man i really wish i had points in our
tree right about now
i do have gunpowder how do you make
bullets we need the forge we need click
you just clay
god you need a lot of stuff just find
bullets please for the love of god
um i got pumpkin seeds just as good
we'll load him in a sling and we'll fire
at him unfortunately it's the best i've
gotten out of this
you have looting power
i'm gonna go loot even though i'm not
specialized to loot like you
i will do my best i'm gonna buy a point
in looting
i'm also gonna buy a point in archery
and i already have one
all right whatever yes what's up just
out of durability on stuff
out of mana healer's down can't rise
all right that all sounds par for the
course
gun safe yes that's what i like to hear
i got i got like five ten locked i don't
even know how many locks
all right we're getting in the [ __ ] give
me give me give me give me
no bullets
i've got a pipe bomb that'll do oh i
sold some of those
okay never mind patrick told me it was a
bad idea to sell them
after i sold them oh you know well what
does patrick know
honestly nothing i don't think
i don't think he knows nothing i think
we got we got some stuff
i got 39 nine mil 28 762
junk turret a bow iron arrows that is
what daddy likes to hear
a level five knife level four iron spear
that is what me
daddy likes to hear uh do you wanna know
what you don't like to hear
what don't i like to hear cooks my
mentor is full dump
some stuff just drop it on the ground
prioritize
oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] oh the attack
the war there's a shotgun messiah
there's a store a gun
store here go dump some stuff meet me at
the gun store it's where i am put my
bedroll down
and i found death but don't
schedule are you dying
you cannot die do not die
we're all good bed roll is down i'm
still very uh
what's the word uh not good
diseased oh yeah i forgot about that
yep that's still a thing i'm putting all
of our good important stuff in this gun
safe
which gun safe i don't know what gun
safe you're at why
mark we're gonna live here this is a
good place to live what do you mean
we're gonna live here where
uh up oh okay up
i don't even see your your thing on the
map anymore
zoom out no like if i look northeast
east south like oh hey you're west hey
buddy
[Laughter]
god i don't need armor i found grenades
okay we're gonna blast the ass
of every single zombie i can't believe
i'm in a gun store
12 bullets there's no bullets man
there's
no bullets how what i got some uh
for you what was that words there's a
gun safe over here are you coming to the
gun store
i am now in the north i told you
meet me mark i'm going to forget where
this building was
did you put your bed roll in there yes
oh hey you're west of me
i found you i'm on my way oh my god
if they make a case study of like the
worst teammate in a crisis
situation i think you're the one
it's raining men yes
are you coming to loot this or you know
what forget it yeah okay basically here
all right there's a gun safe in here
yeah i
know i can sense it's full of bullets
packed to the brim
of nothing but bullets all right which
side's the entrance
front door that's a big wolf i see that
wall
it's kind of in my way a little bit well
no it's not
where's the big safe at in the back that
way we
are going to crack the safe
we are going to crack the state
gonna crack this crack the safety [ __ ]
my lock picks
what all right come to me i got some i'm
dropping them on the ground you
take you you got all the lock picks
actually before you
open these by looking look at these
boxes real quick look in these boxes
done i took some ammo out of one you can
take the rest good stuff good stuff
thank you was it good stuff did you get
good stuff uh oddly enough yeah
where did you set up your base where was
your base big
stone tower that is east
what i cracked safe uh a four-time
scope mod a level five machete some
money and some
[ __ ] and some ammo good good no shotgun
shells though
are we holding out in the big stone
tower
that's where all my stuff is there's a
lot of
stone towers it's nothing but stone
towers
i'm on my way i've got three barbed
wires
put down i've got 74 so we're good
hey buddy i've got a battery back over
here i've got a better idea
you putting ladders or something i'm
climbing
what don't fall then are you is your
stuff at the tippy top
uh close to it yeah the top floor that's
like not destroyed
this is the roof there's only that oh i
see ah i see
my bed roll is not here so i'm gonna
make another one and i'm going to put it
in here by the oh hi
all right so stairwell they can come up
this stairwell they're going to come up
the stairwell
question mark yes i think that's the
only way they can get in other than if
they're
magical and fly they can climb the
ladders well they're real easy to kill
if they're on the ladder so i think
might be their own demise they are
climbing the la
and fast wait how fast
oh very fast okay this was a mistake oh
my god
and i'm should i destroy the top part of
the ladder i'm gonna put that there
what a fool what fools you've been made
fools of
stupid fools i think they gave up
where'd they turn out why
did i grab i didn't grab a melee weapon
god damn it i'm an idiot
they're on the roof oh i'm just watching
mark
that guy just walked right by me to come
to you
oh i'm stunned i'm out of health
all right i'm over there oh oh martin
how are you getting here oh the other
ladder and i'm capping off these ladders
oh mark they they broke through on the
left-hand side yep
what if like my bullets aren't even
doing anything i mean at this point
melees
oh never mind your bullets were doing
the thing turns out it was your bullets
were doing way more than my melee was
i got some good news i got some bad news
yeah what's up good news is i'm reloaded
bad news is there's no more reloading
all right well you don't need it get a
blade out get a blade out come on
blademaster
dude i'm slicing and dicing i should put
points in blademaster this is great
get down oh yeah get gone ow
i got hit oh
this doesn't seem good all right i'm
busting out the shoddy
completely out of ammo all right that's
okay it's okay looks like they're
completely out of zombies
uh zombies
oh god i've got 10 health don't die
well
[Laughter]
oh it was eating your corpse i was just
watching it oh my god he's so fat this
one's going for a double kill
oh my god i'm back
magically back from the dead please be
the end of it
it feels so good to be cold yeah man i'm
very infected
maybe you should maybe i should that
seems to be the easy way
you know me they call me easy way mcgee
oh we're getting big ones oh
that guy jumped right over
hey we did it
just die die die
so about defending this place it's not
ideal no the other one seemed to be a
lot better
glad we changed at the last second oh
there's a [ __ ] barbed wire yes
so we weren't getting out and they
weren't getting god
just get our [ __ ] out of there and i'm
going to the trainer mark i've got
zombies you're fine
oh look one of us hasn't died one has i
think i know
what the deal is goodbye wade
goodbye i'll see you around did you take
my money i put in the storage
what are you talking about i really wish
i did though at this point i
really really wish i grabbed your money
you would just take the motor bike and
leave
i would yeah i really would have i would
have done that 100
oh my god there's so many that's
unfortunate for you
oh jesus oh god oh no no i'm getting
boxed in
no where did you all come from oh jesus
nope jesus
ooh hey oh [ __ ] good news my dude i
found a level 5 ak
all right good did you find level 5
bullets
no you seem to be low on health yeah
yeah this tower is uh full of zombies
man
that sucks oh yeah right on your penis
oh yeah right on the penis you get that
penis
i'll be right back okay there's a mini
bike if i sell everything i have
let's sell the basic stuff first let's
assume that no refunds
wade's not getting this he doesn't need
it he doesn't need the better
machine gun he's gonna find one i
believe he's gonna find one
sell sell okay i'm a 9 000.
i got to sell like my machete if i sell
the chainsaw i'm there but i'd rather
keep the chainsaw
i might as well repair these they sell
for better value if you repair them
so i'll just repair them and then
sell them and then i'll be good to go
sell that 11 000 i'm very close
yes hey
what's up what's up what's up not much
uh
chad was telling me to check my my the
weapons safe they said you robbed me but
i see my tokens so i think
i trust you robbie what oh my god
i can't believe people would think that
why would i do that
no way i wouldn't do that to you you
know why
you know why no i have no you're a team
we are a team okay we're team
t-e-a-m-e is for two of
us traveling together e
is for everyone loves me
what a is for always be there beside you
m is for mark is trustworthy
okay all right that that checks out it
seems legit
it is legit it is actually very legit
but is it supposed to be team work
should there be a w o r k w
is for wade he's the best in the world
o is for orange for the bangles
and that i know you like r is for raron
to go
down the road and what was the last
letter okay
k is for you'll be okay
okay that's horrible
no celtic this is horrible come on
horrible wow that's a little
rough okay it's for you'll be okay yeah
you'll be okay you know you'll be okay
mark where are you where are you going
what are you talking about where are you
uh where are you heading
where am i heading like where are any of
us heading you know
it's like a philosophical question you
can't really really put no it's pretty
it's pretty straightforward
[Laughter]
what are you talking about what what's
up nothing how are you
a little concerned uh you're a little
hey buddy i found you what
fun found me mark what is that what
what's up what's up what
what's up hey sorry i gotta go tunnel
weird
interference that's
strange
[Laughter]
such strong words i wouldn't have
thought you would
stoop so low you know that's why chat
said you betrayed
me betray you what oh my new wheels
oh gosh this is my sweet new ride
dude my dude my man look liz
[Laughter]
where are you at come here come here let
me let me talk
i'm hitting air with an axe why are you
hitting air with an axe
oh just working all right well that's
good man good
for you good for you i say
you still have the uh that level five
gun and ammo
what the aka remember that aka level
five
i don't remember ever mentioning that oh
my god
what what's up i am being betrayed chad
mark's betrayal is his gift
for your birthday all right wait you
know thanks buddy
mark mark give it died right no i
haven't died
guess what i got for you buddy old pal
since i know you're not betraying me
you know you know what else i got for
you
the mini bike's yours it's all yours
and these are vitamins and not these
don't
[Music]
wait
you